bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat six ans après la
disparition du commissariat général du
plan
faut-il inventer aujourd'hui une
nouvelle planification stratégique pour
mieux guider la prise de décision pour
répondre à cette question la délégation
à la prospective du sénat et le conseil
économique social et environnemental ont
organisé hier une rencontre autour de
deux grands témoins les anciens premiers
ministres jean-pierre raffarin et michel
rocard pour tenter d'apporter une
réponse à cette question ce matin je
vous propose donc de revoir en partie à
cette rencontre bonne matinée à tous
monsieur le président du conseil
économique social et environnemental
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois qui devraient pas tarder à
nouveau à nous rejoindre
messieurs les présidents des délégations
à la prospective du sénat et du conseil
économique social et environnemental
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs mais
dans des messieurs prenant la parole il
faut immédiatement que je me confondent
en excuses puisque à peine orages
terminer cette brève introduction que je
devrais m'éclipser ce sont les
contraintes liées à ma fonction
mais je le ferai d'un choeur peut-être
plus léger sachant que monsieur le
premier ministre mon collègue jean
pierre raffarin vice président du sénat
sera immédiatement avec vous pour
participer à vos travaux
c'est donc avec un grand plaisir que le
sénat accueille ce colloque sur les
défis du long terme et sur la nécessité
d'une vision stratégique pour guider les
décisions politiques organisés par les
délégations je salue mon collègue joël
bourdin à la prospective du sénat et du
conseil économique social et
environnemental ce sujet et tout
particulièrement d'actualité puisque
le premier ministre a reçu hier de
madame yannick moreau présidente de
section conseil d'état que je salue le
rapport de la mission qui lui avait été
confiée sur la création d'un nouveau
commissariat à la stratégie et à la
prospective
il est d'actualité également plus
largement parce que nous avons besoin de
prendre de la hauteur par rapport à un
temps médiatique qui ne favorise pas la
prise en compte du long terme et par
rapport aux évolutions de plus en plus
rapide de la société
la désindustrialisation de notre pays le
réchauffement climatique l'augmentation
des prix des matières premières et
alimentaires permettent de constater les
difficultés que nous rencontrons pour
anticiper et même pour réagir à temps et
avec la force nécessaire face à des
phénomènes qui semble toujours nous
prendre de vitesse
il m'est arrivé de réfléchir à l'avenir
du bicamérisme et en particulier de
cette assemblée et j'ai toujours
considéré qu' il était peut-être de
notre responsabilité d'avoir une
dimension un peu spécifique notamment
par rapport à l'assemblée nationale et
d'essayer de nous situer dans une vision
plus prospective plus à long terme je
crois que le sujet d'aujourd'hui nous
montre que cela est tout à fait
nécessaire
en effet la question de la prospective
se pose aujourd'hui pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord on peut se rappeler que
la planification française a montré dans
le passé qu'elle pouvait être réducteur
d'incertitude je cite je cite
l'expression du commissaire général
pierre macé elle a également permis la
réalisation de succès industriel et la
création de champions nationaux et
européens par exemple dans les secteurs
de l'énergie de l'aéronautique et du
spatial
les ambitions industrielles d'alors sont
d'ailleurs encore largement de
l'actualité assurer l'indépendance
énergétique de la france
encourager le développement des
industries nouvelles fournir un cadre
approprié à l'évolution des structures
et aux réformes indispensables de notre
tissu industriel en voilà qu'il s'agit
de thème d'aujourd'hui
alors il ne s'agit pas bien évidemment
de
répéter ce que nous avons dit ou fait
hier nous vivons désormais dans une
économie globalisée à la fois très
ouverte mais aussi encadré par des
règles des règles européennes des règles
mondiales et surtout nous avons
l'obligation pas seulement d'ailleurs
politiques et économiques mais aussi une
obligation morale de redresser nos
finances publiques ne pouvons plus comme
dans les années 60 70 ou plus récemment
comme certains pays plutôt asiatique
l'ont fait faire porter par l'état le
lancement de nouvelles filières
industrielles nécessitant des
investissements de départ considérable
émettant des années atteindre un seuil
de rentabilité ne pouvant envisager de
tels efforts qu'à l'échelle européenne
et j'ajoute que nous devons les
favorisés dans ce cadre en particulier
dans cette période de difficultés
économiques
et tandis que le projet européen doit
trouver un nouveau souffle pour autant
je crois que nous ne vont pas conclure
trop vite à une impossibilité d'agir est
considéré que l'état devrait être
cantonné à un rôle de je ne sais quel
observateur parfois de régulateur des
forces de marché
l'état peut arrêter une stratégie il
peut définir des priorités dégagées les
moyens et encourager des initiatives
nous l'avons vu avec des investissements
d'avenir qui ont été un exercice de
prospective et je veux saluer michel
rocard qui a été un des principaux
artisans pour définir des priorités mais
aussi pour mobiliser les moyens publics
privés des moyens nécessaires à leur
mise en oeuvre
nous avons besoin dans une période où je
le redis tout s'accélère d'élaborer des
stratégies à moyen et à long terme qui
ne se limite pas à la prise en compte
des contraintes immédiates et ne s'égare
pas dans des considérations théoriques
nous avons besoin qu'une instance de
prévision de réflexion de concertation
puisse également impulsé la réalisation
de ce dont nous avons besoin c'est à
dire de nouveaux projets
la représentation parlementaire et les
partenaires sociaux dont vont avoir leur
place dans ce travail d'évaluation et de
prospective qui sert l'intérêt national
je souhaite donc que nous puissions avec
bien sûr les délégation à la prospective
du sénat et du conseil économique social
et environnemental réfléchir aux outils
qui permettront d'insuffler un nouvel
état d'esprit et de relever les défis de
donneurs mesdames et messieurs je vous
souhaite pour cette après midi de
fructueux travaux et je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président bonjour à
tous sur le plaisir d'animer vos deux
ces deux tables rondes et 7,7 après midi
très très riches comme vous allez le
voir et à laquelle nous espérons bien
sûr vous associer avec vos questions et
vos vos commentaires dans un temps jeu
s'annonce d'ores et déjà un peu
restreint mais c'est la loi est la loi
du genre nous avons beaucoup à dire et
d'abord première remarque pratique nos
débats sont enregistrés captation par la
télévision public sénat
et ils seront intégralement reproduit
compris d'ailleurs je pense le débat
avec la salle
vendredi 7 d'antan dans deux jours à
10h30
voilà pour votre information faut que
vous le sachiez donc alcoologue qui va
être consacré la planification
stratégique à ces nouveaux moyens aussi
que l'on pourrait mettre en oeuvre pour
inspirer les décideurs publics
c'est tout cela que nous allons parler
je vous présente les invités pour cette
toute première table ronde qu'elle donc
tenteront de devoir en discutant quelles
améliorations on peut attendre d'une
planification renault rno v puisque nous
avons quasiment déjà fait le constat
qu'elle était nécessaire
nous attendons le jean pierre raffarin
en effet l'ancien premier ministre vice
président du sénat qui sera avec nous
dans un instant jean michel charpin
économiste ancien commissaire au plan
viendra nous parler de cette de se
passer et du commissariat au plan et de
ce qu'ils espèrent aujourd'hui voir
advenir hugues de jouvenel qui est ici à
ma droite président délégué général de
futuribles internationale sur les
travaux déjà en sciences le lire 2
de futuribles portant a également sur le
très long terme ce sera des objets du
débat le court terme le long terme
michel ruffin et chef du service
prospective études d'observation
territoriale évaluation de la datar là
encore nous rappellerons le rôle qu'a
tenu la datar et celui qu'elle occupe
aujourd'hui comprise qu'elle occupera
dans une éventuelle configuration
différente et enfin le pire à la chine
participe aussi à notre débat il est
conseillé à le céder le chef des projets
sur l'avenir et nous apportera quelques
comparaisons utiles avec des pays
voisins au plus lointain d'ailleurs
qu'ils ont à ses yeux assez bien réussi
ces questions de mise en place d'une
planification et ne concluront notre
table ronde bien sûr avec joël bourdin
président de la délégation à la
prospective du sénat
la deuxième table ronde sur les moyens
les outils que nous aurons à mettre en
oeuvre pour une nouvelle planification
stratégique sera introduite par l'autre
président à la délégation à la
prospective lui et au season commencer
c'est jean paul bailly notre grand
témoin sera aussi politique michel
rocard ancien premier ministre ancien
ministre du plan et de l'aménagement du
territoire
et puis nous aurons avec nous
l'économiste yann algan mélanie gratacos
pour les associations au cee yannick
moreau donc présidente section conseil
d'état qui vient de remettre ce rapport
s'est éteint hier c'est au frais
certains d'entre vous l'ont peut-être
déjà eu l'occasion de le voir mais nous
en parlera donc ce rapport au premier
ministre jean pierre sueur président la
commission des lois du sénat et jean
paul delevoye président du conseil
économique social environnemental
viendra clore nos échanges
eh bien nous allons commencer peut-être
avec vous jean michel charpin si vous le
voulez bien
revenons rapidement sur le passé ce
n'est pas le plus important mais années
60 70
donc le commissariat au plan avec sans
doute dans les années suivantes une
légère désaffection des intérêts
peut-être si vous qu'elle est corrigé si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord
et au fond devant quelle situation
sommes nous aujourd'hui
avez vous le sentiment que les
différentes instances différents
organismes qui ont été créés après la
suppression du commissariat au plan
on remplacer et sinon où sont les
banques jean-michel certains mon souhait
c'est après midi c'est con on est en
regard tourné vers l'avenir et qu'on ne
se contente pas de cultiver la nostalgie
de cette époque et de notre jeunesse
mais je comprends que par nature ayant
occupé les fonctions de commissaire au
plan il est normal que je revienne un
peu sur le passé si on met de côté la
fonction très particulière qui
consistait à préparer les projets de
lois de plomb qui avait vocation à être
soumis au parlement mes fonctions qui
s'était en fait interrompu au début des
années 90 moi ce qui me frappe c'est que
toutes les autres fonctions du
commissariat général du plan ont été
reprises depuis sa suppression par
d'autres organismes ce qui montre
d'ailleurs que ses fonctions était
nécessaire d'une certaine façon et qu'il
a fallu continuer à les assumer même
après la suppression le centre d'analysé
stratégique a repris la fonction de
veille d'études prospectives
le conseil d'analysé économique s'occupe
des liens avec la recherche économique
le commissariat général à
l'investissement a commencé à reprendre
la fonction portant sur
le choix des investissements publics se
dit qu'il a commencé parce qu'il l'a
fait principalement pour l'instant dans
le cadre du grand emprunt est il
envisagé d'étendre sa l'ensemble des des
investissements publics la fonction
d'évaluation a été reprise pour partie
par la cour des comptes et pour partie
par d'autres organismes administratifs
et la fonction de concertation été
reprise à la fois de façon permanente
par des organismes comme le conseil
d'orientation des retraites
le ceo le le haut conseil de l'assurance
maladie ou du financement de la
protection sociale aussi le grenelle qui
qui était un grand exercice de
concertation et même récemment la grande
conférence sociale ou la conférence
environnementale est relevé et
finalement du même type de logique donc
toutes ces fonctions ont été reprises
est-ce qu'elles l'ont été dans des
conditions satisfaisantes sur les
fonctions de veille d'étude et de
prospective qui ont été reprises par le
centre d'analysé stratégique
j'ai trouvé l'âne et kz2 du rapport de
yannick moreau un peu sévère je n'ai
aucune responsabilité dans les travaux
du centre d'analysé stratégique fêtait
les utiliser comme simple lecteur j'ai
trouvé dans cette situation de simples
lecteurs qu'ils ont produit pas mal pas
mal de travaux intéressants
je dirai la même chose des débuts du
commissariat général à l'investissement
qui me semble intéressant aussi le
conseil d'analysé économique a produit
aussi des choses utiles donc je ne serai
pas outre mesure moins sévères vis-à-vis
de de ces différents organismes
c'est la fonction qui à mon avis a le
plus souffert de la substitution a été
la fonction de concertation et
d'ailleurs je me réjouis que
dans le rapport de yannick moreau cette
fonction soit particulièrement mise en
avant parce que elle a été menée de
façon abondante comme je l ai dit tout à
l'heure il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de
concertation ces dernières années mais
je trouve que les méthodes qu'ils
étaient employés par rapport à celle qui
existait du temps du commissariat
général du plan souffre et souffrait de
deux défauts relativement important
lesquels on lit ça le serpent est ce que
c'est parce que peut-être c'était une
concertation qui passait un peu trop par
commande dans la médiatisation ou est ce
qu'elle vous ont paru un peu hâtive ou
est ce que l on aurait mérité peut-être
de se rapprocher davantage de l'
expertise comment est-ce qu'on vous
définiriez ses défauts il ya plusieurs
configurations il ya eu effectivement
beaucoup d'exercices de concertation je
dirais mené dans la journée les grandes
conférences auxquelles je faisais
allusion par exemple la conférence de
michel rocard sur la taxe carbone
c'était des concertations qui démarrait
le matin qui se terminait le soir et qui
donnait lieu quasiment à des annonces
dans la foulée on comprend bien pas que
par rapport à la méthode qui était celle
du commissariat il ya un général du plan
ou même la méthode qui est encore celle
du conseil d'orientation des retraites
du conseil d'orientation de l'emploi
c'est très différent parce que quand
elle les concertations sont menées sur
une certaine durée
il y a de la discussion entre les
partenaires il y a un certain ajustement
des problématiques des conceptions de
chacun et au total c'est beaucoup plus
fructueux évidemment que quand on réunit
les gens dans la journée ou en fait on
peut procéder à une consultation de
cette façon là mais on peut certainement
pas à voir le type d'interaction qui
était menée dans le cadre du
commissariat général du plan
la situation de l' expertise mon
expertise a toujours joué un rôle
fondamental le commissariat général du
plan vous savez comment ça se passe et
il y avait des commissions dans les
commissions et avaient tous les
partenaires qui étaient représentés
autour de la table et l'introduction des
séances étaient faites par des experts
qui précisaient les concepts qui donnait
l'état de réflexion des chercheurs et
l'ensemble des partenaires réagissait
par rapport à ces apports des experts
c'est vrai que dans la période récente
il ya eu des procédures différentes pour
des raisons d'ailleurs qu'on peut
comprendre par exemple si vous prenez le
grenelle moi j'ai un peu participé au
grenelle même pas mal le grenelle ça
marchait pas comme ça hein
le grenelle ça marchait pas comme ça ce
qu'il veut pas dire qu'ils aient pas des
experts autour de la table mais ils
étaient autour de la table justement ils
pouvaient être contredit par n'importe
quel autre membre disons il était à la
même position que n'importe quel autre
intervenant dans la discussion donc
c'était c'était un positionnement assez
différent que je peux comprendre dans le
cas du grenelle parce que les sujets
abordés par le grenelle sont des sujets
controversés souvent y compris en
matière d' expertise mais la méthode du
commissariat général du plan
au moins sur les sujets de type
économique ou social avait quand même
beaucoup davantage ya merci jean michel
sapin nous saluons bien sûr l'arrivée
jean pierre raffarin qui vient de nous
rejoindre je m'adressais tout de suite
est tout de suite avoue on vient donc
avec jean michel serre pas d'évoquer
l'histoire récente la fois celle du
commissariat au plan et puis surtout des
organismes qui lui ont succédé pour jean
michel charpin le dirait si vous en êtes
d'accord est là le bât blesse peut-être
du côté de la concertation concertation
a peut-être un peu trop éloignés des
experts si on s'est bien entendu et
peut-être aussi parfois même assez
souvent trop rapide
jean pierre raffarin revenant sur votre
longue expérience de ces questions
n'insistait pas sur les lorrains vous
savez c'est mal dit un homme qui reçoit
une gifle est un homme jëf les un homme
qui reçoit l'hommage est un homme âgé
donc donc je suis très peu d'enjeu la
fin de ce que je n'entende g charpin me
va très très bien je suis très heureux
de remercier joël bourdin de m'avoir
invité de le féliciter pour la manière
dont la délégation au sénat sur la
prospective et est conduite
sur le fond je pense que en effet la
concertation est un élément très
important mais la concertation dans une
perspective sur un regard sur une vision
et pas seulement sur les urgences et
l'actualité et sur l'immédiat également
alizée quand l'immédiat dévore l'esprit
dérive donc le point important et c'est
je pense moi qu'il faut crier
aujourd'hui notre besoin de réflexion de
stratégie de moyen terme
je ne comprends pas pourquoi dès que
j'ai tourné le dos de matignon on a
supprimé le commissariat au plan et
confond on a mis la datar de manière
subalterne dans des institutions
secondaires
je pense que la stratégie le moyen terme
c'est un élément majeur du système
est-ce qu'on a regardé un petit peu les
taux de croissance dans le monde
aujourd'hui et s'affole personne de voir
que la croissance et des régimes
autoritaires
c'est un système très contrôlé et si
vous lisez le 12e plan chinois regardent
et l'intelligence de ce texte
regardez comme le pays qu'est le premier
pollueur du monde est aussi le premier à
parler de croissance inclusive de cloyes
de croissance verte est d'être le
premier à la fois dans le charbon mais
aussi dans le photovoltaïque c'est à
dire qu'au fond ces pays autoritaires
fond de la stratégie un élément majeur
de leur développement et nous belle
démocratie à laquelle nous tenons et
n'assure naturellement je reste
démocrates et républicains
fondamentalement mais quand je vois que
nous on se laisse posséder par
l'immédiat et que tous les lieux où on
pense l'avenir sont un moment ou un
autre fragilisé je me dis que si on
abandonne cette volonté là c'est
tragique pour notre bataille et
notamment face au match qui est entre
les régimes autoritaires et démocratie
pourquoi ben non non nous les contrats
de plan j'étais le premier à signer avec
lionel jospin dont on connaît les
affinités politiques et les miennes le
contrat université 2000 quand j'étais
président de région les contrats de plan
c'est quand même c'est qu'on avait
inventé c'est michel rocard qui l'avait
fait de mon point de vue de plus
intelligent pour veiller à ce que l'état
affirme ce qui est de cohérent
que le territoire a filmé de ski et
d'initiatives et d'ambition il faut et
naturellement toujours en ligne et eyang
les territoires ils sont là pour
exprimer des libertés des ambitions et
les tailles là pour affirmer des
cohérences et des logiques et des
valeurs de justice notamment et les
valeurs républicaines donc en résumé je
pense que là ce qui est essentiel
aujourd'hui c'est de remettre la
dimension du moyen terme dans nos
décisions publiques et confond plus
personne ne s'intéresse au moyen terme
tout le monde ne gère que l'immédiat
hélas même dans des grands partis
politiques
je note fut effectivement jean-pierre
appareil vous insistez sur le moyen
terme le long terme tout de même à sa
place on va le voir certainement avec
hugues de jouvenel danse et danse est
une des vocations à futuribles vous
séparez vous distinguez moyen et long
terme on sache je laisse les
professionnels distinguer tous à ce que
ce que je crois c'est qu'au fond en
politique il est clair que quand vous
regardez une décision publique
aujourd'hui si vous faites un auditorium
dans la belle ville de poitiers entre le
moment où vous l'avez décidé et le
moment vous l'inaugurer il ya dix ans
c'est donc par les mêmes équipes qui
décide et qui inaugure ce que d'avoir un
problème aux deux pays par ailleurs mais
c'est un sujet très important ce donc à
mon avis aujourd'hui le moyen terme en
chine ces trois ans le moyen terme chez
nous ces dix ans et le long terme chez
nous ses 30 ans et le long terme chez
eux ces dix ans donc il ya un moment où
il faut ouvrir les fenêtres de la france
et regardez un peu le monde tel qu'il
est jeudi la chine mais ce qui me frappe
le plus c'est de voir ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui au brésil où le brésil est à
la fois un pays qui tous les deux mois
on voit ses comptes publics
parce qu'il estime que les rentrées
fiscales sont pas au niveau et ses draps
et donc il serre les boulons et des
serre les boulons en fonction de
l'actualité budgétaire à 2 mois mais en
même temps ils ont des stratégies
compris fédéral de politique à moyen
terme et à long terme et donc ça je
pense qu'il faut qu'on s'habitue à ce
qu'est la gestion complexe et la gestion
complexe et qu'évidemment les médias est
très important et immédiat est très
important pour la démocratie mais le
moyen et le long terme son très
important aussi
il est clair que quand vous regardez
kate aujourd'hui le processus de
décision
pour nous le processus de décision et
elle que nous avons une notion de moyen
terme qui est trop longue
il faut revenir à des processus de
décision qui à mon avis sont plus
courants donc le grenelle de
l'environnement dont mathieu charpin est
un des acteurs
le grenelle de l'environnement c'est
très bien si ça n'arrange pas trop les
délais du moyen terme pour en faire en
fait des délais de long terme
merci pierre alain cl je pense que j'ai
écouté avec intérêt ces comparaisons au
pays et surtout ses visions différentes
aux fonds du moyen terme du courtier
profitons de de votre à voile ocde pour
connaître un peu ce que font les autres
mais personne n'a vraiment là le modèle
parfait de la planification mais quand
même dit non quels sont les bons
critères selon vous en tout cas pour une
planification réussi mon après-midi
messieurs dames
je pense que la première chose peut-être
sept présentés le fait que l' ocde en 34
pays membres la prospective stratégique
s'est développée depuis 1975 et à
trouver la forme d'une unité permanente
depuis 22 ans maintenant donc nous avons
une certaine expérience de ce qui se
passe dans un certain nombre de pays ce
que je crois c'est bien sûr il faut
d'abord commencer par des stand et
planification et prospective stratégique
parce que je pense que jusqu'à présent
on est un peu sur les deux niveaux donc
c'est quelque chose qui sur lequel il
faut être peut-être un peu plus clair
quelques remarques sur les mécanismes
institutionnels à la suite de ce que
vient de dire monsieur le président
raffarin ils ne sont qu' il y a des
solutions relativement intéressante qui
doivent même remonter jusqu'aux parfois
jusqu'au niveau de la constitution
nous avons bien citer le cas de la
finlande pour lesquelles
le premier ministre quand il fait son
discours de l'union doit présenter la
vision de la finlande à 15 ans donc on
est bien dans cette notion plus ou moins
de moyen terme
donc effectivement ça ne vaut pas
forcément un engagement ou un programme
de politiques publiques pour les 15 ans
à venir mais c'est quand même quelque
chose d'intéressant d'avoir d'une part
cette notion de l'homme politique le
plus puissant qui vient d'être élu
déclare ce quelle est sa vision du pays
à 15 ans et ça se traduit aussi au
niveau parlementaire par l'existence
d'une cote d'une commission permanente
sur l'avenir donc peut-être que c'est
une invitation pour ceux qui nous
écoutent aller dans ce sens là alors il
ya d'autres bien sûr et des exemples
plus restreint que qui ont aussi un cil
quand les abandons dans les reprend
comme les offices d'évaluation des
technologies dans les structures
parlementaires dont on sait qu'elles
sont bien sûr plus restreinte que les
questions de retraite ou les questions
de longévité ou des questions de
changement climatique
mais c'est peut-être aussi qu'une
évolution qu'on voit dans d'autres pays
c'est la réapparition de ce besoin de
regarder le long terme à travers les
politiques de sciences et technologies
et l'évaluation des technologies et bien
aussi sur le mécanisme institutionnel
des choses intéressantes qui se passe
traduit en français la cour des comptes
des états unis maintenant s'est arrogé
je pense qu'on n'a rien changé à son
mandat le forme de d'appréciation des
politiques à long terme
donc quand le gouvernement l'exécutif
des états unis où le congrès se saisit
d'un certain nombre de questions aime
bien la cour des comptes fait une espèce
aussi d'appréciation préventive j'allais
dire de décisions qui auraient un
caractère prospectif donc éventuellement
des engagements à très long terme que
prendrait le gouvernement donc il ya un
certain jeu aujourd'hui dans un certain
nombre de mécanismes relativement
institutionnels pour réapproprier le
long terme dans les questions de
politiques publiques
alors je veux pas trop occupé le temps
par contre les réussites les plus
récentes sont bien sûr moins ambitieuses
elles sont surtout des réussites
sectoriel il ya des réussites en matière
de politique de sciences et technologies
par exemple au danemark
il ya des politiques sur le financement
et la planification à long terme des
infrastructures en suisse
un certain nombre de pays donc pour
l'instant personnes à retrouver
finalement le la formule magique pour
réintroduire le long terme dans les
politiques publiques
mais bon nous espérons que c'est quelque
chose qui va progresser et donc le
caractère créatif aujourd'hui de ces
mécanismes ont fait ce renouveau de ce
débat on le voit aussi avec le fait que
peut-être une planification raisonnée
pour reprendre le titre aujourd'hui de
la réunion ça va aussi peut-être avec la
remise en cause certains tabous alors
nous savons qu'on a les politiques
publiques on n'a pas trop le droit de
parler de politique industrielle on n'a
pas le droit de dire que le gouvernement
pourrait inciter de façon relativement
concrète des initiatives dans les choix
technologiques
donc si on veut aujourd'hui retrouver la
croissance et peut-être se poser un
stand de questions de refondation des
économies des pays ocde
il faut peut-être remettre à plat aussi
un certain nombre de chalets dire de
grands tabous qui qu'il faut pas
forcément jeté aux poubelles mais qui
par groupes qu'il faut rediscuter au
niveau de leur postulat pour pouvoir se
donner des grottes degré de liberté
restons encore un instant sur les
exemples que vous avez pris le danemark
par exemple nous dit notamment le
politique des sciences et technologies
c'est bien cela et vous avez parlé
d'appréciation préventive
j'aime assez le terme parce que
peut-être que c'est ce qui peut nous
manquer ici en france en la prévention
on va y revenir à ce qu'on évalue bien
avant même d'agir
peut-être que jean pierre raffarin veut
rassurer mais là dessus aussi mais dites
nous pourquoi ça vous paraît ainsi bon
exemple danemark
je crois qu'au danemark simple je parle
même pas de lexie sécurité mais nous
avons au moins deux ou trois exemples
récents de surtout le caractère inclusif
participatif de des procédures alors que
ce soit cet exemple sur les sur les
politiques de sciences et technologies
qui a mélangé si on peut dire des
conséquences l'analyse du long terme le
point de vue des experts et y compris le
point de vue des populations
l'engagement des
ministre des ministères yeux des
ministres donc on revient peut-être sept
contrats de plan il ya contrat met donc
je crois que c'est un élément encore une
fois de très important ils ont fait
aussi les mêmes efforts sur des
particularités de la politique de santé
et on retrouve une espèce de constantes
dans le modèle des pays scandinaves en
général et la grande question je pense
pour un certain nombre de pays qui nous
occupe c'est un effet de taille pourquoi
des pays à 10 millions d'habitants
arrive à trouver des mécanismes inclusif
participatif est une notion de consensus
alors que à 60 80 millions ca ça paraît
beaucoup plus difficile alors il ya
peut-être une question de verticalité il
ya des solutions à trouver
c'est beaucoup des très bons exemples
sont des exemples de pays ou de
structures démographiques à 10,15
millions d'habitants je crois que vous
citez volonté singapour aussi pourquoi
singapour d'ailleurs singapour
il faut peut-être hésité à les mettre au
parlement parce que c'est une ville et a
donc c'est sûr ils ont injustement la
facilité qu'on vient de décrire d'être
une très forte imbrication de tous les
décideurs dans un espace géographique
extrêmement restreint donc c'est sûr
qu'ils ont des belles réussites mais il
faut se remettre aussi dans ce contexte
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour une
ville état que encore une fois une
population de 80 ou 100 millions
d'habitants bien sûr réactions peut-être
est-ce que nous dit pierre-alain chip
soc et comparaison pays seuls présidents
bourdin si vous le souhaitez ou jean
pierre raffarin comparaison qui
effectivement doivent être ramenés à la
taille de chaque état vous le dit bien
jean pierre raffarin ou d'autres cas
logique du consensus qui est quand même
une pensée qu'il ya derrière ces
mythologies n'est pas forcément lié à la
taille et au fond mais pour coûts liés
au mécanisme
il est clair que le fait qu'il y ait des
lieux où les consensus peuvent se
préparer et très important je pense que
dans notre pays on donne pas aux cee
je salue le président bailly co
organisateur de ce colloque
je crois que clermont n'a pas donné
suffisamment assez d'importance ont lieu
qui prépare les consensus qui
qui au fond sont des lieux où les
opinions s'expriment où les premiers
consensus peuvent se développer et au
fond au niveau national comme au niveau
régional je crois qu'il faut travailler
sur l'ingénierie du consensus parce que
les consensus
y'a que les dictateurs qui les font
comme ça en un clin d'oeil les autres
ils sont obligés de les construire et
les construire sa demande des lieux où
se construisent des consensus et ça je
pense que c'est une une démarche qui à
laquelle il faut qu'on réfléchisse sur
l'ingénierie de désaccord je parlais
tout à l'heure des contrats de plan état
région mais ce sont des mécaniques de
l'ingénierie sociale qui permet de
construire des consensus donc il faut
réfléchir à la méthode dans laquelle on
peut essayer de construire notamment la
participation de la société civile au
consensus
oui de l'utilité d'un oui pardon joël
bourdin je vous en prie sur ce plan je
pense pas excusez moi que là qu'il ya
une corrélation entre entre la taille du
pays et le disons la réussite de la
concertation car on a quand même notre
histoire commissariat au plan a
fonctionné
il réunissait différentes catégories de
personnes
c'était une véritable ruche qui
travaillait on arrivait à monter des
opérations et des plans c'était des
plants sains qui finalement est était
cohérent et et au moins pour certains
qu'un aboutit au résultat qui était
souhaité fallait peut-être dépoussiérer
sans pour cela je mets absolument
on verra dans un instant on reviendra
sur le rôle de la datar a toujours été
présente avec michel ruffin auparavant
quand même avec vous et de jouvenel ce
que vous entendez la sueur au fond les
les apports de la prospective dans les
politiques publiques franck ça n'est
plus à démontrer mais on y travaille
depuis très longtemps futuribles quelle
définition donneriez-vous enfin comment
reviendriez vous sur l'utilité de cette
prospective
merci mais j'aimerais d'abord remercié
la délégation à la prospective du sénat
us et the d'après l'initiative
de cette réunion en vue de réintroduire
la dimension du temps long dans la vie
publique je dis pas dans les tâches dit
dans la vie publique c'est pas la même
chose
j'aimerais ensuite réagir très
rapidement les chansons vient d'avoir
parce que finalement viennent d'être
débattu de questions celle du long terme
c'est quoi le long terme c'est qu'en bon
mais c'est vrai qu'on attend ça parler
du futur sans dire à quelle échelle de
temps si tu as tendance à penser que
toutes les échelles de temps sont
pertinentes et si on travaille sur le
climat rond va pas travailler à la même
échelle de temps si on travaille sur le
développement au service de voisinage
d'accord donc les périmètres et les
échelles de temps sont pas les mêmes
c'est une première remarque trivial
la deuxième remarque tout aussi triviale
c'est de dire bien sûr le long terme
c'est important mais avant d'arriver au
long terme faut quand même passer par le
court et le moyen terme et donc dans une
démarche de prospective à langer revenir
sur ce mot si vous le voulez bien
il ya ya la démarche on part du présent
pour aller explorer le champ des
possibles et puis à la démarche on part
d'un objectif qu'on se fixe dans le
futur et où on revient sur le présent
pour savoir qui fait quoi demain matin
donc je vais revenir un instant à du
troisième réaction par rapport à les
changes qui vient de s'instaurer
je crois pas du tout qu'on puisse dire
qu'il ya une pareille à laquelle on peut
faire de la prospective les aimants qu'à
une autre
moi je vois dans les territoires des
petits territoires et des grands
territoires qui font d exercice de
prospective très intéressant on a parlé
de singapour on a aussi évoqué le 12e
plan chinois moi j'ai eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec les auteurs 12e plan
chinois
ils ont des visions à long terme il y a
on a parlé du danemark mais on pourrait
parler d'autres grands pays je crois pas
que la taille du pays où la tare du
territoire sont un élément déterminant
alors ça c'était une réaction un peu un
peu à chauds est maintenant sûre sur le
long terme
moi je suis très attaché à une
distinction entre l'avenir comme
territoires à explorer et l'avenir comme
territoire à construire d'ailleurs
delors dont on qui est cité dans le
rapport d'un mode assist lui aussi
sur cette distinction l'avenir comme
territoires à explorer sa part d'une
première chose qui est quelles
représentations nous forgeons nous de la
situation actuelle à charge pour nous
d'essayer de faire le tri entre ce qui
relève de l'écumé des jours et qui sans
doute fera la une des médias et puis ce
qui d'un autre côté va nous apparaître
comme symptomatique révélateur de ce
qu'on appelle classiquement des
tendances lourdes et des phénomènes
émergents
j'ai envie de dire des racines de futurs
possibles ensuite vient la question du
copo t'il advenir
et là moi je suis très attaché à la
nuance qu'il convient de faire entre la
prévision qui repose sur des modèles de
simulation et puis la prospective qui
s'efforce de prendre en compte les
phénomènes de discontinuité de rupture
ainsi que les acteurs qui sont en scène
et la stratégie des acteurs et les
acteurs fort heureusement ce sont des
êtres humains ce sont des corps sociaux
qui fonctionne pas de manière répétitive
se sont pas des automates ou des romo et
c'est tant mieux
donc c'est des gens qui fonctionne aussi
avec une fibre une fibre sensible et
alors de ce point de vue là j'en profite
malheureusement nick moore est parti
mais c'est vrai que quand je vois dans
son rapport une assimilation qui est
long terme prospective égale prévisions
macroéconomiques je dis attention c'est
pas vraiment ça et quand je vois par
ailleurs dans le même rapport
montez un peu en épingle une soi-disant
controverse entre les tenants de la
prospective du présent incarné ici par
jean paul bailly
et puis la prospective je sais pas quoi
plus classique moi j la prospective du
présent et nourrit la réflexion sur
l'avenir
les avenirs lits sont en germe dans le
présent alors ça c'est une chose c'est
prospective sera fort son seul objectif
c'est de mettre en évidence les enjeux
et avant de faire du consensus sur les
enjeux moi je dis il ya un vrai défi qui
est d'être capable d'instruire des
controverses féconde sur les questions
qui font problème si on fait du
consensus ont fait du prince eu souvent
à côté de la question
et puis ensuite il ya l'avenir comme
territoire à construire et ça ça passe
par une réflexion à trois niveaux
quelles sont les marges de manoeuvre des
différents acteurs l'état est un acteur
parmi d'autres c'est pas le seul quelle
est la représentation que la puissance
publique
où l'état se forge d'un avenir
souhaitable et réalisable
c'est ce que dit louis gallois dans son
rapport quand il dit l'état doit donner
une vision à long terme
c'est quoi cette vision à long terme qui
anime les politiques publiques j'en sais
rien et puis on supposer qu'on est un
objectif à long terme qui soit
clairement définie vient la question du
compte à rebours qui fait quoi quand
comment pour y arriver mais en bas ça va
s'appuyer sur ces trois hypothèses en en
parlant évidemment avec michel ruffin
d'abord de la datar alors la tradition
d'avatar là on est bien dans la
réflexion prospective 1 vous confirmez
michel refaire on n'est plus dans la
prospective que dans la prévision
si l'on évoque le cachet de la data est
ce que ça peut être là d'ailleurs une
différence avec le co avec l'ancien
commissariat au plan
alors on avance à peu je surveille ça
michel charpin oui enfin je pense qu'il
ya il ya un discours un peu classique
c'est-à-dire le commissariat au plan
souvient votre micro de o faisait de la
faisait là prévisions macroéconomiques
de la modélisation et puis la datar
faisait de la prospective donc nous nous
étions un peu les créatifs et les
économètres pour caricaturer forcer le
trait je suis pas certain que ça rende
compte de sava justice or aux deux
institutions
mais effectivement je vous confirme que
la datar et davantage positionné sur le
créneau prospective si on peut dire
peut-être essayé d'expliquer pourquoi
dès hier soins parce que bon s'il
fallait caractériser la datar je dirais
qu'elle a plusieurs caractéristiques la
première c'est que c'est une entité une
institution une délégation qui croise
l'action et la stratégie je pense c'est
un premier élément à voir clairement en
tête pour comprendre ce qui la structure
depuis l'origine la voir très
prochainement 50 ans c'est l'âge des
bilans c'est aussi l'âge de faire des
projets d'avenir
et donc voilà premier premiers points
vraiment importants et qui pour le coup
là nous différencie bien de ce qu'était
le commissariat au plan ou de ce qu'a pu
être le cas ce qui lui a pour partie
succéder c'est ça c'est ce tuilage dirai
plus ou moins réussies selon les époques
mais en tout cas permanent dans la durée
entre réflexion stratégique prospective
étude d'une part et puis portage soit en
direct soit conjointement avec un
certain nombre d'institutions de
ministères de politiques publiques
que ce soit les pôles de compétitivité
les contractualisations et
région car je vais pas les citer toutes
mais il faut vraiment voir ce cette idée
en tête
deuxième élément important qui
caractérise la data est assez que de par
son objet même elle et j'allais dire
abonnés autant l'eau puisque tous les
enjeux d'aménagement du territoire
c'est comme pour l'urbanisme enfin les
transports etc
on traite de sujets monsieur raffarin
c'était le cas l'auditorium quand il
s'agit de lignes de transport quand il
s'agit de désenclaver des territoires
etc
on est sur des perspectives là qui pour
le coup sont même plus à 15,20 parfois
trente ans que sur les dix ans qui les
banques et donc par définition la datar
est obligé de façon un peu constitutive
et c'est bien pour ça que dès les années
60 a dès l'origine il ya une forte
tradition prospective qui s'est mise en
place à la datar avec pour ambition
justement comme l'a rappelé hugues de
jouvenel de d'identifier quels étaient
les futurs possibles
encore une fois ce qui distingue
peut-être le plus la prospective de la
prévision
il ya peut-être un effet de délai d'
horizons temporels éventuellement les
méthodes mais c'est aussi l'idée que on
fonctionne beaucoup plus par scénario
parce qu'on considère que le futur n'est
pas écrit et que justement il ya
plusieurs options possibles et tout
l'enjeu
ces options pendant votre le principe à
la datar et de proposer plusieurs
scénarios bien sûr c'est une hausse et
un ballon travail donc il ya eu
plusieurs exercices aussi du temps qui
ont donc un exemple fort qu'on vous
aurions tous ont en mémoire
éventuellement alors il ya eu des
quelques scénarios qui ont fait date
comme celui qui restait sous le nom de
scénario d' inacceptable pour décrire
alembon après tout dépend des des choix
que l'on veut faire mais celui là il
reste un tollé mémoire il ya l'exercice
n - à qui était la france 2030
on est actuellement en train de
travailler sur un travail un peu au long
cours qui s'appelle territoires 2040
j'en dirai peut-être un mois près sur le
point suivant
ce qui me paraît il me semble c'est une
démarche assez novatrice et qui mérite
d'être d'être un peu plus approfondie
mais voilà l'enjeu vraiment sur quoi je
voudrais insister c'est que par
définition la datar ne peuvent vivre
qu'avec des visions du temps long
et que ces visions ne sont pas donnés à
priori et que donc il faut les
construire et comme le rappelait hugues
de jouvenel avant de faire du consensus
il faut déjà se dire quels sont les
grands les grands moteurs des
transformations de la société et du
territoire français et donc à quoi à
quel type de grandes images on peut
arriver quel type de futurs possibles on
peut arriver pour ensuite voir justement
comment on peut prendre des décisions
que ce soit sur les infrastructures de
transports l'aménagement numérique
j'écoute ans et la data pardon et en
faisant une question peut-être pour pour
tous craquer de zone elle voulait déjà
réagir à ce que vous venez parce que
vous êtes en train de me dire mais au
fond conseil d analyse stratégique plus
datar n'ont ils pas suffisamment rempli
ses fonctions puisqu'il se sont
retrouvés sur de nombreux projets ce
qu'ils n'ont pas utile mans remplacer ce
qui se faisait au commissariat au plan
je demande aussi un jean-michel sorte
avec de jouvenel michel réfère à parler
de petits moteurs et de grands moteurs
moi ce que je constate aujourd'hui dans
les territoires c'est que les grands
moteurs ce sont les territoires au
niveau des métropoles au niveau des
départements niveau des communautés
d'agglo c'est pas les temps l'état est à
tout petit moteur en retard d'une guerre
par rapport à ce qui sort matière de
prospective dans les territoires sous
l'impulsion de collectivités
territoriales ça c'est un premier point
sur lequel je intervient le deuxième
point c'est être en décalage par rapport
à ce qui vient d'être dit je vais
prendre un exemple sur prévisions
prospective qui en taquinant mon ami
jean michel charpin que je respecte
beaucoup et pascal amoureux n'a rejoint
et qu'ils ont tous les deux joué un rôle
majeur sur la prospective des retraites
qu'est ce que c'est une démarche de
prévisions en matière de produits ti des
retraites et met ses jardins jean michel
charpin fait un rapport majeur qui
depuis d'or est tenue à jour par le
conseil d'orientation des retraites
c'est un travail de simulation
macroéconomique donc ici vu le
fonctionnement et les françaises comme
ci ait pas de rupture majeure dans son
organisation collective et ses
simulations reposent sur des hypothèses
les hypothèses en l'occurrence et on
prend la projection médiane des
projections lycée puis on fait des
hypothèses sur la croissance économique
la productivité et l'emploi
parce que je constate dans le dernier
rapport du cor exactement comme non le
rapport charpin
c'est que ces hypothèses souvent sont
très arbitraire subjective discutable
donc dernier rapport du cor soul et on
nous dit la croissance va repartir vers
sur des gains de productivité importants
on sera un taux de chômage de 4 à 6 % en
2001 en 2020 voilà on peut tourner de
faire tourner modèle derrière mais je
tirais les résultats ils valent pas
mieux que les hypothèses d'entrée alors
par rapport à ces démarches là moi il me
semble que la prospective ce qu'elle
apporte je dis pas que c'est une fierté
elle a une vertu magique mais je dis que
quand on travaille sur des pattes sur
des horizons temporels l'on a là donc
sur une dimension temporelle où il peut
y avoir des discontinuités drupe des
ruptures éventuellement qu'on peut
vouloir provoquer discontinuer des
ruptures
il faut pas raisonner toutes choses
égales par ailleurs jean-michel certains
souhaitaient aussi réagir peut être
d'autres à cette table on va dans un
moment donner aussi la parole à la salle
bien entendu comme celle de remarques
la première est fondée sur la
distinction qui a été utilisé par hugues
de jouvenel entre l'exploration et la
construction de l'avenir concept qui me
paraissent tout à fait pertinente parce
que c'est vrai que dans la démarche qui
a toujours été la nôtre ou celle des
prospectivistes on commence par explorer
les à venir les avenirs en essayant
d'avoir d'imagination et d'envisager des
scénarios divers mais on le fait on le
fait pour éclairer des décisions on le
fait pour justement permettre la
construction de l'avenir
et s'il n'y a pas là la deuxième étape
la première peut avoir un intérêt
intellectuel ou ludiques mais tel que
c'était pratique et au commissariat
général du plan ou même à la datar
d'ailleurs c'était bien dans le but
d'éclairer des décisions à prendre
aujourd'hui ou à prendre dans un avenir
proche
deuxième remarque sur sur le long terme
qui est plutôt dans mon esprit une bonne
nouvelle j'ai beaucoup été frappée
depuis une quinzaine d'années que alors
même que on stigmatise à juste titre le
court termisme de beaucoup d'acteurs des
journalistes des financiers des
entreprises
simultanément les problématiques du long
terme sont devenus plus plus familière
d'ailleurs y compris aux journalistes y
compris aux journalistes
je trouve qu'il est plus facile
aujourd'hui de faire comprendre les
problématiques des retraites puisque
j'ai beaucoup travaillé ce sujet du
développement durable des politiques
climatiques des grands choix
d'infrastructures que ça ne l'était il y
a quinze ou vingt ans période qui est on
était un peu coincé sur l'horizon des
plans finalement on est et on était avec
des horizons de 5 à 10 ans et le très
long terme était beaucoup plus difficile
à appréhender par les observateurs par
les commentateurs
j'en veux un voir un symptôme technique
ou technocratique dans l'évolution du
taux d'actualisation du plan dans les
années 60 et 70 le taux d'actualisation
recommandé par le commissariat général
du plan était de 8% en termes réels
pour ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent
la mécanique des taux d'actualisation ça
veut dire que tout ce qui se passe au
delà d'un horizon de 10 ans n'a plus
aucune importance parce que le taux
d'actualisation cumulé réduit à zéro
tous les montants qu'on peut envisager
aujourd'hui plus personne n'envisagerait
de travailler avec des taux
d'actualisation ou si élevé ce qui
traduit sous une forme arithmétique en
fait le fait qu'on qu'on a allongé
l'horizon et dont beaucoup d'exercices
aujourd'hui finalement l'opinion est à
ses prêtres raisonner à long terme
peut-être aussi parce qu'elle a beaucoup
appris là ça serait il la pédagogie il
sans doute qui a été fait de la part je
ne sais pas des experts voir des
politiques
c'est leur phare de jouvenel peut-être
d'autres réactions encore je vous en
prie moi je suis ici si vous voulez bien
sûr ce que vient de dire jean michel
charpin je crois qu'il ya 10 une
première chose tout à fait importante en
disant l'exploration des futurs
possibles n'a d'intérêt que dans la
mesure où ça débouche sur la
construction de la future souhaitable
oui absolument oui avec une nuance c'est
que l'exploration des futurs possibles
ne peut pas porter exclusivement sur la
france il faut prendre en compte le rock
il faut prendre en compte le monde donc
le périmètre de la réflexion est très
large
alors que la construction du futur la
france étant pas maîtresse du monde et
les voies publiques françaises ayant pas
la main sur tout ça implique quand même
de savoir que le périmètre de l'action
publique et notamment publiques national
il va être différent du périmètre de
l'action de la réflexion de la réflexion
prospective au sens au sens large du
terme
donc ça c'est c'est un élément alors
maintenant par rapport à ce qu'est ce
que disait jean michel charpin sur le
fait que nos contemporains finalement
avait une plus grande intelligence du
futur raison plus pour pas les prendre
pour des imbéciles
raison de plus pour ne pas leur fournir
des prévisions macroéconomiques explique
embarrasé gratis demain matin le rapport
damas moreau à juste titre souligne la
crise de confiance qui en france
notamment vis-à-vis des instances
publiques et aussi vis-à-vis les autres
on sait très bien que la france arrive
en queue de peloton depuis très
longtemps sur les baromètres de la delà
de la confiance
elle arrive juste au dessus de
l'afghanistan pour la ligne tu dit une
petite idée là je pense que là le
discrédit des instances publiques
nationales et les instances publiques
locales n'ont pas le même disque riz le
discrédit instances publiques nationales
quintaux fait qu'on raconte n'importe
quoi et qu'on ne donne pas de visibilité
ou qu'on donne des projets qui sont
manifestement est réalisable
donc on prend les gens pour des
imbéciles les gens malheureusement sont
de moins en moins imbécile est donc là
il ya un petit problème il faudrait
quand même que allah au sein de
l'appareil d'état
on se fait un peu à l écoute de la
société comptant un peu plus en phase
avec les réalités qui on est et 2 ou
celle là je parle de ceux qui sont
supposés incarner
au sein de l'appareil d'état la
réflexion alors je sais pas s'il faut
dire prospective stratégique
j'irai la fonction autrement est ce
qu'il y a une responsabilité politique
dans ce la transmission de ces chocolats
sais pas c'est pas qu'il ya des
coupables je reviens une seconde sur
l'exemple de la retraite moi je suis
absolument pour les réformes qui ont été
introduits sur les régimes de retraite
d'accord mais faut bien voir je reviens
sur roy parle de jean michel charpin qui
pour moi est un rapport tout à fait
important il l'a fait une époque où
l'insee penser qu'à partir de 2006 la
population active avait commencé à se
réduire parce que les générations
nombreuses du baby-boom elle est
massivement partira en retraite
à telle enseigne qu'en 2010 on allait
dérouler le tapis rouge pour les seniors
et pour les jeunes c'est pas vraiment ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui comme c'est pas
donc c'est pas parce que jean michel
charpin est mauvais c'est pas parce que
l'insee mauvais c'est pas ce que on est
aussi très largement tributaire des
lunettes qu'on a sur le nez des
indicateurs qu'on utilise en
l'occurrence est l'indicateur de
fécondité 1 plutôt que le nombre de
naissances par année il n'y a pas eu un
grand crac au niveau du baby crack ya
pas eu un grand boum ou donc ça donne
une vision et rodez l'a aidé donc moi je
crois que au niveau de l'aide appareil
d'état et quelle que soit la création
d'une commission d'une délégation de je
sais pas quoi encore
a prospective autre chose il ya aussi un
gros travail à faire sur les indicateurs
sur les données sur la manière dont vont
se représente aujourd'hui la société à
la fois dans ces variables qu'on appelle
dur à ce qu'on croit être capable de les
quantifier et dans ces variables qu'on
qualifie de molle mais qui souvent sont
beaucoup plus motrices que les variables
dur en vérité le serveur s'est voulu
intervenir aussi aux réactions voilà de
jean pierre raffarin de joëlle bourdon
et simplement tout ça c'est vrai qu'il
ya des difficultés mais si je prends ma
dame
le rapport du cor c'est grâce à ça qu'on
a pu faire la réforme celle que j'ai
menée en 2003 parce que dans les débats
du corps qui était à la fois technique
et en même temps de concertation
j'ai identifié que la cfdt un certain
nombre de partenaires majeurs avaient
des positions communes donc c'est dans
ce travail à la fois
dirait de diagnostic des analyses mais
en même temps d'expression de volonté
politique qu'on a pu définir un chemin
et je suis c'est lionel jospin qui avant
moi avait construit cette démarche et je
pense qu'elle a été très utile et que le
corps a été le lieu qui dans sa
diversité à montrer à qui voulait avoir
de la bonne volonté
un chemin donc je pense que cette ces
questions là sont très importantes et si
monsieur charpin a raison de dire qu'au
fond le long terme est de plus en plus
présent dans un certain nombre de
réflexions
c'est une bonne chose mais je crois que
je salue monsieur michel rocard qui
vient de nous rejoindre
un ancien premier ministre ça mérite
toujours le respect et on s'arrête et
donc je le salue affectueusement et
respectueusement et tout ça pour dire
qu'il ya un certain nombre de sujets
quand même sur lesquelles on voit bien
que la réforme passera par de la
prospective la réforme des retraites est
passée par de la prospective cd
consensus qui ont été bâties sur des
analyses
or aujourd'hui on voit bien que dans ce
qui est engagé sur la maîtrise des
dépenses publiques on voit bien qu'il ya
deux sujets qui sont majeurs
un l'éducation nationale de la dépense
sociale et notamment la dépense de santé
est ce que sur ces deux sujets là on a
des approches type core c'est à dire des
lieux où on réfléchit à la fois sur le
moyen terme à la fois sur la prospective
pour préparer des initiatives parce que
s'il n'y a pas ce travail en amont il
n'y aura pas de consensus en aval un
silo et troubles en amont on a assez peu
de chances d'être clair en aval donc je
pense qu'il faut quand même réfléchir à
ce type de méthodologie et c'est pas
parce que vous êtes là madame que je
salue cette action mais je crois qu'il
ya des lieux dans la société ou s'ils
ont progressé en matière de prospective
on peut aussi progressé aujourd'hui dans
ce qu est au fond la stratégie de
réforme par une réflexion en amont et
j'ajoute je le disais tout à l'heure je
leur dis parce que michel rocard nous
nous a rejoints sur les contrats de plan
je pense que au lieu de se poser en
permanence la question de savoir si nous
sommes trop jacobins outre aux girondins
bâtissons est prolongée
les contrats de plan était de ce point
de vue là une belle clairvoyance c'est
de se dire au fond que l'état assume ses
missions que les territoires assume et
concret des lieux où se rencontrent les
stratégies et ont bâti des politiques
contractuelles sur des stratégies qui
sont en partie différentes mais qui ont
des intérêts communs et c'est ça je
crois une forme de prospective
opérationnel à laquelle il faut penser
mini d'accord que si votre réforme des
retraites allait dans le bon sens
elle est tout à fait insu elle était
tout à fait insuffisantes
bien sûr mais le bon sens ça suffit a
beaucoup de choses parce que les
réformes dans le mauvais sens sont
encore pires
agrégé et que évidemment sur des sujets
de cette nature vous ne pourrez les
faire que par étape et que de toute
façon la réforme structurelle comme ça
elle peut se bâtir que par étapes
d'ailleurs la réforme en question
prévoyait des étapes de révision mais de
toute façon vous ne réformez pas
l'éducation nationale à l'occasion d'une
rentrée voudrais faire un point la
politique de santé à l'occasion de la
sortie d'un médicament
ce sont des actions de long terme qu'on
fera que par étape et c'est pour ça que
la prospective est très importante parce
que c'est elle qui donne un sens aux
étapes mais le corps avait donné à
donner une ligne directrice ou après
pour des conditions politiques sociales
économiques
chacun choisit le ripper les actifs
choisi mais ont choisi le rythme mais la
direction est fixe et autres réactions
politiques à domicile refaire un nouveau
vol bourdin seront plus interdits en
vous appuyant dit je réagissait aux
propos de jean michel charpin que je
partage complètement sur les taux
d'actualisation car effectivement il
nous rappelait tout de suite que
lorsqu'on élaborer des plans et quelques
années le taux d'actualisation comprenez
pour évaluer les les actions futures
c'était 8% 1 et je voulais dire que la
prospective
elle est liée à l'évaluation qu'on fait
du présent sans dévaluation vraiment des
actions présentes ou du passé récent on
peut difficilement faire la prospective
scala prospectifs on l'a rappelé tout de
suite ce sont des scénarios
or les scénarios on les fait à partir
d'hypothèses les hypothèses où on les
cherche
on les cherche dans dans les évolutions
les évolutions récentes et donc
j'insiste là dessus on ne peut pas faire
d'abord prospectives si on n'a pas une
bonne évaluation et les deux démarches
sont sont voisines d'ailleurs haut
commissariat au plan
on faisait aussi d'évaluation de dire le
commissariat au plan c'était aussi un
commissariat d'évaluation l'évaluation
et à continuer à continuer son chemin un
et et donc on ne peut plus comme on
avait la prétention de faire quelques
années faire des prévisions assez fine
parce que c'est impossible
1 et on est obligé de manier d'état
d'état des tas d'hypothèses qui
finalement se se révèle complètement
désastreux mais les scénarios les gros
scénario oui on peut le faire
1 et la prospective ce sont des
scénarios un deux trois quatre scénarios
et et dans ses scénarios il faut voir
quels sont ceux qui sont cohérents mon
on est déjà dans la planification quand
on commence à imaginer la cohérence et
là c'est peut-être justement l'occasion
de redemander un ami c'est vrai sens à
quintin begins a évoqué les territoires
2040 là on est vraiment sur plusieurs
scénarios
je suis je peux rebondir bien sûr
préalablement sur au moins
d'interventions précédente et faire un
peu de provocation pour dire que
finalement faire la prospective
ça va dans les deux sens c'est à dire
que l'exploration qu'on fait du futur
permet aussi de comprendre le présent et
que ça et c'est peut-être ça aussi qui
différencie l'exercice prospectif de
l'exercice de de modélisation ou de
prévisions c'est que ça marche dans les
deux directions et que c'est à force
aussi de construire des scénarios pour
essayer de comprendre ce que pourrait
être l'avenir qu'on arrive à dégager
quelles sont les tendances structurantes
du présent et à mieux comprendre ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui donc je suis très
attaché enfin et quand je dis je c'est
la date à 0
à cette vision du sujet et encore une
fois on n'est pas juste dans la
projection sur l'avenir on est dans
l'identification de variables
stratégiques et la compréhension de ce
qui est en train de se passer
pour pouvoir identifier les bons leviers
d'action pour pouvoir prendre des
décisions et évidemment je me retrouve
tout à fait dans l'entreprise et
monsieur fortin de si on fait de la
prospective
alors il peut évidemment y avoir une un
vrai plaisir intellectuel a essayé de
d'imaginer l'avenir mais encore une fois
c'est d'abord pour prendre des décisions
c'est pour construire ma stratégie c'est
pour faire réagir et d'enjeux donc j'en
arrive à cette voie là est l'enjeu donc
on peut parler effectivement l'exercice
territoires 2040 qui était un bon qu'à
l'école
l'enjeu c'est d'arriver justement alors
on a changé un peu de braquer par
rapport aux exercices antérieurs de la
data qui d'emblée essayer de construire
deux trois quatre scénarios sur l'avenir
de la france à 10 ou 15 ans ou 20 ans là
la posture de départ a été relativement
différente elle a consisté à se dire
finalement peut-être qu'il faut pas
raisonner à priori sur l'objet france
ont donc tel il faut raisonner par type
de territoire puisque c'est un des
enseignements qui était lié à nos à nos
démarches antérieures ou aux études
qu'on mène parallèlement qui était de
dire finalement les territoires français
se différencie de plus en plus ils ont
chacun des potentialités différentes et
sociales message fort que je voudrais
passer c'est que le futur qu'on peut
observer
il n'est pas le même selon la maille à
laquelle on observe c'est à dire que on
n'observe pas la même chose quand on se
pose la question de l'avenir de la
france ou de l'europe où quand on ne
réfléchit à l'avenir d'un territoire qui
peut être une ville ou une vie d'état ou
une région donc c'était tout l'enjeu de
territoires 2040 c'était d'identifier
les grands types de territoires
aujourd'hui à l'échelle française
donc on a regardé les espaces de faible
densité on a regardé le périurbain on a
regardé les métropoles mondialisée on a
failli ne pas les citer tous mais pour
vous donner quelques exemples de la
façon dont nous avons raisonné et de
produire des scénarios donc à horizon
sur chacun de ces espaces donc on a pas
on est incapable si vous posez la
question on est incapable aujourd'hui de
dire à quoi ressemblera la france en
2040 en tout cas on n'a pas encore fait
l'exercice
de ce type mais on est capable de dire
de façon un peu robuste ou documenté
comment pourrait évoluer les territoires
périurbains où les grandes métropoles
mais s'il attend vous avez fixé
l'escadre ans quelle que soit la pour
une réflexion futur voilà et encore une
fois cet exercice il et il est très très
intéressant parce qu'il fait réagir
enfin j'ai eu l'occasion de le présenter
à l'assemblée nationale il ya quelques
jours et c'est vrai que les élus locaux
qui se reconnaissaient dans tel ou tel
type de territoire était enfin réagi
c'est vraiment et c'est ce que je leur
ai dit l'enjeu c'est aussi ça la
prospective là pour donner une vision
d'ailleurs on a eu une vraie réflexion
c'est aussi une spécificité forte de
territoires 2040 sur la façon dont ont
représenté l'idée était de dire on ne
fait pas que des scénarios écrits ont
fédéré des scénarios cartographique
visuel et donc on a construit des cartes
totalement dédiée à l'exercice qui sont
qui sont pas des cartes traditionnelles
qui sont assez innovante et dont on est
assez fiers et donc à la fois donc le
texte et la carte sont là pour donner
une représentation un peu brutale
j'allais dire des différentes options
proposées les différents scénarios
construit et ensuite donc faire réagir
et faire agir c'est le discours que j'ai
porté encore une fois l'exercice c'est
toujours stimulant intellectuellement il
a mobilisé de nombreux chercheurs à
l'échelle nationale internationale mais
l'enjeu n'est pas ça l'enjeu c'est de
dire bon quand on arrive à ça comment
les acteurs locaux comment l'état
s'approprie ce matériau et canadaeast
quels sont pour vous les rapidement
michel des femmes et quand on vous
entend fonds engagés tout ce travail on
s'est dit mais vous aurez vous besoin
d'un
nouveau record il s'appellera du nouveau
commissariat à la prospective ou
considérez vous qu'une allemand vous
fait pour bien ce travail je vais vous
dire qu'on fait très bien son travail
mais c'est une vraie question sont nos
questions de nature différente
la façon dont on peut s'organiser pour
bien le faire et la qualité du travail
que j'ai présentées sont deux choses
différentes
et puis sérieusement quelle
complémentarité voyez vous voilà je
pense qu'il peut y avoir des
complémentarités fort alors je parle de
la situation actuelle donc sans présager
des décisions qui pourraient être prises
puisque vous savez que pour la datar il
ya également des réflexions en cours sur
des évolutions possibles mais il est
clair qu'il ya déjà des rapprochements
peut-être plus systématique a opéré par
exemple entre la datar et le casse
absolument indispensable même si nous
n'avons pas forcément les mêmes pas de
temps même si d'emblée le cas ça plutôt
une vision nationale et nous essayons
d'avoir une vision à plusieurs échelles
a encore une fois ce que je vous ai dit
sur territoires 2040 se veut être la
datar ne va plus s'occuper que le
territoire infranationaux ce n'est pas
l'idée mais d'idées fortes que nous
avons derrière ça c'est de dire qu'il
faut raisonner à plusieurs échelles du
local à l'européen et au mondial et que
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à construire
des stratégies de développement
efficaces gérer actions encore de
jouvenel jean-michel sherpa jean pierre
raffarin qui veut commencer juste 3 1 ce
qui est très important c'est que le
scénario est un média dans un monde
numérique
quand vous avez un scénario vous avez
beaucoup d'informations se comportent
scénarios sont pas d'information ce
conte des scénarios c'est important je
me souviens avec la terre on avait monté
un concept avec olivier guichard sur
l'arc atlantique
du temps où la région poitou charentes
et est active parenthèse c'est une
balise simplement pour mes quelques
collègues qui sont là mais je pars
statut dans simplement pour dire que il
ya quand même un élément très important
aujourd'hui c'est que saisir les
informations c'est aussi un facteur
d'intelligence et que si vous êtes sans
information vous vous êtes très faibles
donc le scénario vous donne des
informations mondial très important
premier point de deuxième point la carte
il ya de la malice chez la datar 1 parce
que la carte c'est un lieu de pouvoir
jeudi aux élus qui sont ici pour faire
très attention que j'avais j'ai monté
dans ma propre région un institut de
cartographie parce que celui qu'a
l'écart pas souvent le pouvoir
donc il faut pouvoir leur poser des
cartes à nos valeurs car parce qu'au
fond derrière une carte il ya toujours
une idée est celui qui a fait la carte
et n'est jamais innocent donc il faut
toujours être pas attentifs à ce qu'ils
font des cartes et donc ne pas laisser
le pouvoir de la carte comme ça parce
que c'était une expression visuelle
vous avez des grands débats qui se
résume par une carte et le lendemain
matin dans la dépêche du midi dans ouest
france ou ailleurs
la carte sort et l'idée est passé mais
vous avez beau discuter c'est la carte
cas gagné donc ça cette année montrent
les derniers points dernier post
scriptum je me réjouis que la datar soit
redevenu interministériel parce que 70
de rhodes dans le thermique est rattaché
à matignon qu'elle trouve tout son
espace stratégique nécessaire
je ne sers pas un pic de juillet et
ensuite on ira dans la salle compromis
nous avons tout à fait le temps oui je
vais essayer de répondre sérieusement
même si je souhaite pas être trop long à
l'interpellation critique du duc de
jouvenel sur les travaux qui ont été
menés sur les retraites
est-ce que les scénarios qui ont été
utilisés tout au long de ces travaux
était un peu trop rose comme une me le
reproche depuis plus de 15 ans la
réponse est oui
il était effectivement biaisé dans le
sens de l'optimisme
mais pourquoi est-ce que ce choix était
fait ce choix a été fait parce qu'il
faut bien comprendre quelle était la
situation aussi l'objectif c'est
l'action c'est à dire c'est la réforme
il faut arriver à convaincre la
population
les syndicats qu en aucun cas les
techniciens n'ont cherché à noircir le
paysage parce que c'était sa leurs
questions leurs questions c'était est ce
qu'on nous raconte pas des histoires en
nous disant que la situation est si noir
que ça que les déficits prévisionnels
sens si important que ça remettez-vous
en tête la situation dans les années 90
sans être trop long années 90 la
population française et enfin
parfaitement satisfaite de son système
de retraite système universel système
qui a considérablement
réduit la pauvreté parmi les personnes
âgées système qui a assuré la parité de
niveau de vie entre les actifs et les
retraités et là arrive des gens michel
rocard pour commencer puis d'autres mois
vers la fin des années 90 les gens du
corps ensuite qu'ils disent vous êtes
parfaitement satisfait de votre système
de retraites mais tout simplement pour
des raisons démographiques et
financières il est intenable et donc il
faut le changer c'est quand même très
difficile d'arriver à convaincre une
population et ses représentants
légitimes qu'il faut en passer par ce
type de réformes et si les scénarios
avaient été aussi noir que ce que me
conseillez hughes
à l'époque je pense que la force de
conviction auraient été beaucoup moins
fortes
parce que les gens auraient dit
évidemment vous trouvez les déficits
monstrueux mais si ici à la récession
s'est pas de création d'emplois
évidemment c'est pas très étonnant et au
total au total on a fait pas si mal que
ça sur les retraites
aujourd'hui il n'est pas vrai il n'est
pas vrai que la france soit en retard
sur les autres grands pays développés en
matière de réforme des retraites alors
que il y a vingt ans c'était extrêmement
vrai il ya 20 ans nous étions très très
en retard et aujourd'hui ça n'est plus
vrai donc l'objectif pratique qui était
de faire la démonstration de la
nécessité de la réforme a été finalement
atteint on n'a pas réglé aujourd'hui
votre petite querelle de 15 ans avec de
jouvenel n'ont pas eu raison stratégique
ne l'était pas dit non mais jean-michel
pose un vrai il vrai question quand même
il dit si on veut faire passer la
réforme il faut avoir une prévision qui
n'effraie pas la population
et moi je dis si on fait une prévision
trop optimiste on on encourage
l'irresponsabilité et et par conséquent
ne relève pas le défi qui évoquent et
michel rocard dans son livre blanc sur
les retraites
dix ans un gouvernement s'il a un peu de
courage il y va il se contente pas envie
raffarin de réforme paramétrique
provoque délibérément du scanner on les
remet au début des débats
c'est une première la deuxième remarque
2 3 ou 5 par rapport au débat première
remarque qui n'a pas été fait me
semble-t-il depuis le début d'autres
échanges c'est que quand on parlait du
commissariat général du plan du passé on
parlait d'un passé où l'état était
puissant sur un territoire relativement
fermé aujourd'hui l'état est un acteur
parmi d'autres sur un territoire
beaucoup plus ouvert donc il faut
prendre en compte ce phénomène là si on
ne prend pas en compte on se rend pas
compte que les marges de manoeuvre de
l'état sur son territoire ne sont non
plus rien à voir avec ce qu'elle était
il ya 40 ans
deuxième remarque sur en réponse à ce
que disait joël bourdin sur la
difficulté de la prévision tout le monde
sait que la prévision est difficile
lorsque surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de
l'avenir et surtout s'il s'agit de venir
à très long terme
mais c'est pour ça chers amis qu'il faut
renoncer à des équations ultra
sophistiqué à l'horizon de 50 ans avec
des prévisions à long terme qui sont
éminemment périssables on le voit bien
il faut débroussailler l'avenir avec une
à gros traits à la hache
et puis ensuite parce se demander quel
que fait-on moi je crois que c'est pas
en améliorant les méthodes de
prévisionnel qu'on va s'en sortir
3 troisième remarque sur l'évaluation
moi je crois que l'évaluation des
politiques publiques est un vrai enjeu
mais c'est pas l'air gpp la révision
générale des politique moi ce que j'ai
lu de plus pertinent sur l'eur gbp
c'est des travaux qui ont été faits dans
les années 70 sur la rcb la
rationalisation des choix budgétaires le
contrôle de gestion est utile mais
insuffisant l'évaluation des politiques
publiques impliquent que les petits
public et des finalités clairement
définis si les politiques s'engage pas
sur des objectifs on peut pas faire
d'évaluation et puis dernière remarque
moi je trouve qu'on fait trop l'un
passant au débat sur les acteurs
où sont les acteurs ou sur les acteurs
des territoires où sont les acteurs des
associations ou sur les acteurs des
corps intermédiaires
il n'y a pas qu'un seul acteur qui
serait l'état omniscient omniprésent sur
tous les terrains mais si on m'a demandé
dans la salle si élevé je crois que
michel rocard déjà vous les uns
voulaient avoir une réaction à tout ce
qui s'est dit notamment son sujet puis
d'autres réactions dans la salle si vous
le souhaitez dites le nous
chez roccat
si beaucoup sur ce que veut dire
monsieur le journal je dirais volontiers
france ce sera plutôt pour la deuxième
table auront été tout à l'heure j'ai
demandé par l'uicc mans pour réagir et
pour remercier et féliciter ce que vient
de dire monsieur sharp a d'abord merci
d'avoir votre mémoire
mais je vais ajouter une chose que tout
le monde a oublié d'avoir une drôlerie
le commissariat au plan non seulement il
avait fait le livre blanc mais il n'est
pas pour rien dans notre inquiétude
préalable dans les travaux internes
la démographie et parler c'est
probablement le plan que le plus
contribué deux fois quiétude général
mais ce qu'il faut qui si tout le monde
sache alors que tout le monde a oublié
et personne n'aurait que jardin vient de
ne pas rappeler c'est que j'avais mis en
place toute une stratégie compliqué qui
passait par l'accord des partenaires
sociaux est le premier élément de cette
stratégie c'était d'obtenir des
partenaires sociaux le fait d'ouvrir le
débat et d'ouvrir le débat par un
diagnostic
j'ai eu sur le fait de faire un
diagnostic un accord du cnpf et
l'ensemble des syndicats sur neuf cgt
notamment cfdt et fo deuxièmement on a
demandé au commissariat au plan de
décrire ce qu'il a fait superbement et
heureusement qu'ils n'ont pas noirci
monsieur sharp a besoin d'eux mais
ajoute je dirais dans la bo qu'en effet
il procure des pointus une question de
préciser scénario des fourchettes et des
options deux catégories d'options celle
de la puissance publique des
tarifications variés et puis c'est la
démographie qui répondent à d'autres
joies mais mesdames et messieurs les
partenaires sociaux donnaient leur
accord leur publication locaux signée ça
fait partie de l'opération des log et si
bien que le jour où la toute signature
du comesa est europe
ils ont pratiquement disparu c'était
l'état on sortait le livre blanc sur la
fait que vos prédécesseurs avaient
rédigé merci encore j'avais à mes côtés
le cf
la cgt la cfdt et force ouvrière pour
annoncer le diagnostic
et le livre blanc s'était pas seulement
le diagnostic c'était en plus la boîte à
outils sans annoncer aucune mesure c'est
un inventaire de tout clavier des valves
sur lesquelles on pouvait toucher majeur
durer des années de l'utilisation taux
des cotisations tour des frets var d'un
mineur indexation sur les prix ou sur
les taux d'intérêt ou sur les salaires
etc etc taux d'intérêt poi a su qu'à
cela suivez une seconde étape à danser
ce jour là le lancement d'une mission du
dialogue sur les retraites que tout le
monde ait oublié présidée par la
syndicaliste
en l'espèce le secrétaire-général des
cadres force ouvrière fallait un laïc
bien entendu ça l'est un type un peu
réformateur surtout cultivée en matière
économique s'était pas fréquent dans le
monde syndical cgt il s'appelle robert
gates avait flanqué de trois hauts
fonctionnaires avec mission vous avez 2
ans vous patrouillé toute la france
selon les préfectures dans la chambre de
métiers dans les chambres de commerce et
partout il ne faut plus au bout de deux
ans que personnes se permettent de
discuter le diagnostic
cette mission a fait un travail
exceptionnel extraordinaire
ça a duré neuf mois sera pratiquement
suffit j'ai vu mes fonctions prendre au
sein de manière un peu rapide a fait que
le préavis et chacun s'en souvient
j'ai eu le malheur d'avoir comme
successeur quelqu'un qui ne croyaient
pas cette méthode qui a interrompu le
travail de la mission du dialogue sur
les retraites alors que 3 3e étape
c'était après la fin du dialogue sur les
retraites d'ouvrir la négociation
partenaires à 3 l'état le patronat les
partenaires sociaux et la quatrième
étape seulement devait être la loi voilà
ce qui a été adulé et monde est très
éminent collègue balladur a profité du
clae out limare créé par la mission sur
la traite pour procéder par décret en
plein mois de juillet pour au moins les
utiliser une partie de la partie
trésorerie la plus urgente est en gros
la moitié comptablement du problème mais
l'idée était bien c'est le diagnostic et
l'état n'a pas travaillé tout seul
les partenaires sociaux étaient
compromis dans le diagnostic saissac
méthodologiquement c'est ça qui est
important
merci rétrospectivement pour le gourou
du plan
pour le reste les évaluations ni envers
la toile et dire sa deuxième table ronde
on passera le temps qu'il faut sur la
sur l'évaluation et notamment bien sûr
sur l'initiative d'autres voilà dans son
intervention
merci de vous présenter brièvement
monsieur merci greg postel-vinay je
m'occupe de la stratégie de la direction
générale de la compétitivité de
l'industrie et des services et est à ce
titre cette boutique a été un peu pour
quelque chose dans le rapport aux
gallois récemment je voulais souligner
trois points le premier c'est que dans
le rapport de madame moreau
l'intégration de plusieurs organismes
dont le conseil national de l'industrie
ne paraît une excellente idée à partir
du moment où le la composante
industrielle et productive dans la
nation qui est en mauvais état doit
effectivement faire l'objet d'une
attention particulière et au fond nous
sommes à peu près dans la même situation
que celle que connaissait pierre massé
au début des fondements du commissariat
au plan en 10 ans il s'agit de redonner
confiance avec une visibilité et des
perspectives suffisamment attrayante
pour entraîner les énergies et
suffisamment réaliste pour ne pas créer
justement le phénomène de de défiance
qui a décrit très bien et de journal
tout à l'heure donc ça c'est un premier
point le deuxième c'est que l'arbitrage
long terme court terme je pense que la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes en
europe aujourd'hui rend absolument
nécessaire l'intégration des stratégies
nos de nos partenaires européens qui
bouge très vite c'est vrai de l'italie
c'est vrai de l'espagne c'est vrai de
l'allemagne lorsqu'on voit des flux
migratoires de jeunes venant des pays du
sud de l'europe à hauteur de 230 milles
arrivée en allemagne comme espèce de cfa
rebours on a des perspectives qui en
termes démographiques et d'effets sur la
compétitivité sont sans commune mesure
avec ce que nous connaissions auparavant
et donc je vais une deuxième fois saluer
de jouvenel sous la forme il faut que
les scénarios de prospective ne ronronne
pas c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'ils aient
des champs suffisamment large de
possibilités de rupture pour examiner
sérieusement les différentes
possibilités car elles sont larges et
donc
la prolongation par continuité certes
mais en regardant de très près ce que
font les autres
j'ai remarqué que le lg 1er et était
associé aux travaux de madame mandroux
c'est une bonne chose
la troisième élément c'est son sur les
instruments de mesure
il faut des modèles bien sûr il faut des
macro économiste et la direction de la
prévision dans laquelle michel rocard a
fait ses premières armes étaient cet
égard très utile et peut-être aussi très
nuisible je veux dire par là que les
modèles avec la meilleure foi et
l'avenir attention des économistes
travaillent sur des bases statistiques
qui ne reflète pas nécessairement
toujours la réalité actuelle des
entreprises qu'il s'agisse de
l'intérieur de l'interaction entre
industrie et services qu'il s'agisse des
effets des technologies d'information
dont on ne mesure pas toujours là où se
localise la valeur et beaucoup d'autres
effets dans la la communication récente
du gouvernement que je salue concernant
le commerce extérieur on lit tout de
même que s'agissant des services on n'a
pas pu dire grand chose parce que les
statistiques ne disait pas grand chose
donc il y a là un problème sur la
réflexion interne instruments de mesure
qui me semble un outil est une question
majeure
je note que monsieur cause du haut de
ses 101 ans à l'esprit vif et qui vient
d'écrire un article pour expliquer que
c'était encore essentiel et je partage
ce sentiment si monsieur cette
intervention d'autrui beaucoup de main
levée on y va alors monsieur je vous en
prie et devant moi merci également de
vous présenter je crois beaucoup micro
ma carrière à l'union des coopératives
de céréales et des années 60 le
fréquentent l europe
il n'a pas encore été question je ne
propose pas pour aujourd'hui mais pour
les semaines et les mois qui vont venir
une étude de cas pour le panel et tous
ceux qui vont les entoure et pour la
structure qui va être mise en place
les pères de l'europe j'avais une carte
y avait six pays
il allait construire une europe
politique l'europe puissance dont on
aurait besoin aujourd'hui
mais les faits ont été différents nous
avons maintenant si nous faisons la
perspective un ensemble qui est la zone
de libre échange à 27 qui n'est pas
l'europe alors le projet monsieur le
premier ministre le projet il demeure
c'est l'europe puissance il est plus que
jamais nécessaire dans la conjoncture
mondiale actuelle
ma question
la perspective la prospective sur une
avant garde
non la france avec d'autres pourraient
construire les éléments et pas seulement
des communiqués au journal de 20 heures
un travail sérieux une initiative avec
des partenaires sérieux une avant-garde
qu'ils fassent la naissance ou la
renaissance de l'europe l'europe a été
victime d'un avortement provoqué par des
genres extérieur et par les mollesses ou
par le fléchissement de l'intérieur il
faut une naissance de l'europe
l'étude de cas à venir j'en termine par
là ce pourrait être comment réaliser
parle d'avant garde avec qui et comment
l'europe puissance dans l'avenir de
demain
c'est une proposition merci monsieur
d'autres interventions juste derrière
vous conviendra vers ici puis voilà jean
claude devèze pacte civique vos tables
rondes porte sur une planification
rénové quand les le rapport de madame
moreau il ya marqué constitue un centre
de ressources sur différents formes de
concertation et de débat public
en observant la qualité des pratiques
est-ce que ça suffira pour associer les
partenaires sociaux et la société civile
en effet ce aussi nous reportons cette
question sur notre deuxième table ronde
on sera plus sur les outils et les
moyens à mettre en oeuvre après les
constats que nous sommes en train de
faire
merci d'avoir souligné ce point je pense
que yannick moreau il reviendra
parricide ou encore quelques remarques
sont pris aussi la parole c'est très
très simple comment faire les
prospectives et vérification avec les
prolifération des lois et le manque ou
la question de la qualité de
l'autorégulation c'est à dire que à
partir du moment où il ya trop de lois
trop de réformes
chaque année et le scénario elle ne sera
pas très clair
l'autorégulation c'est un élément sahin
clé qui n'est pas encore en france
utiliser et je me rappelle d'un colloque
où j'étais invité pour parler de
l'autorégulation c'est leur relation et
il y avait des difficultés en général
pour savoir qu'est ce que c'est alors
que sur comme les un monsieur raffarin
ce regard y avait le numérique
il y avait plus d'un million d'articles
sur le self régulation autorégulation
france donc comment peut-on faire une
planification de l'avenir
alors que on prend pas en considération
les choses le plus simple des réformes
et où les lois qui sont je parle pas de
loi pénale
mais je parle de loi un général et les
assimiler avec les le droit européen et
international
voire même à l'intérieur de chaque
département français et voilà un peu ce
mot clé c'est le fait que les chéneaux
autorégulation et prospective merci
l'autorégulation jean-pierre afin
peut-être moi je voudrais rassurer
monsieur parce qu'en général si à trop
de lois c'est parce qu'il ya passé de
penser il n'y a pas assez de prospective
c'est parce que l'immédiat dévore et que
plus on met de la stratégie moyen de
textes et c'est la conjoncture qui fait
souvent le texte et si on a une
inflation législative aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'on a une inflation d'attitude
de réactivité et non pas de stratégie de
penser donc plus on mettra de la pensée
dans l'action publique et de la pensée
de long terme et moins on aura
d'opportunisme et au fond c'est
l'opportunisme aujourd'hui qui nous
conduit à légiférer dans un texte qui
est décidé très rapidement dans une
circonstance et ça c'est vrai un certain
nombre de gouvernements successifs
merci vous cette réponse on continue
notre oui monsieur je vous en prie c'est
à vous oui jean françois bay ses
partenaires sociales patronales au nom
des petites et moyennes entreprises
j'ai été acteur de cette concertation et
je peux témoigner de son efficacité
je crois que pour les retraites nous
avons su faire prendre des décisions
responsable raisonnable et financer ce
qui n'a pas été le cas notamment dans le
domaine de la santé et de la protection
sociale et de ce fait nous sommes
aujourd'hui avec une charge de la dette
que nous ne pouvons ignorer tente à
travers la crds qu'à travers de plus en
plus de difficultés à dégager les sommes
nécessaires pour que nous entreprises
nous puissions à côté de l'état
continuer à investir
donc les défis pour demain c'est
peut-être la deuxième table ronde mais
c'est à la fois de trouver les solutions
adaptées à la démographie d'aujourd'hui
et en même temps de trouver les
financements pour aller de l'avant
merci votre voisin on va continuer à
parcourir le l'hémicycle j'aimerais
beaucoup avoir cèdre du liban dans mon
jardin
thiès vous présenter françois rachline
le conseiller spécial de jean paul
delevoye
j'aimerais beaucoup avoir un cèdre du
liban dans mon jardin dit le maréchal
lyautey à son jardinier lequel répond
mais ça prend 100 ans
il m'a jallieu et du dialogue et vous le
planter cet après midi ils vous êtes
d'accord pour dire que le présent est la
conséquence du futur vaste question
réponse évidemment dit on ici
d'autres prix réflexion en question
madame je vous en prie au premier rang
jeu je suis jacqueline denis du je suis
de l'assujetti monsieur rocard et membre
du céser où j'ai commis un avis sur
missions organisation d'états dans les
territoires et qui abordait entre autres
donc je vais aller très très vite
la question de la balkanisation
aujourd'hui des différentes missions qui
étaient auparavant exercé par le
commissariat au plan et donc le beau
besoin non pas de remettre en oeuvre
remettre en place un commissariat au
plan
mais bien de s'interroger de plus en
plus sur l'outil dont nous avions besoin
donc pour plus de prospective et plus de
planification
alors ceci étant dit il ya quand même
trois éléments nouveaux depuis le
commissariat au plan qu'on ne peut pas
négliger
d'une part les leviers d'intervention de
l'état se sont amoindries je ne propose
pas de disputer sur la retraite je vous
le dis franchement mais globalement ça
s'est amoindrie or ça c'est une question
qu'on ne peut pas laisser de côté vous
l'avais abordée au travers de la
politique industrielle
mais il y à d'autres domaines il ya la
décentralisation
monsieur raffarin vous êtes un fervent
défenseur de la décentralisation
c'est un domaine ça joue sur les
questions de prospective et il ya la
construction européenne je m'arrêterai
la construction européenne donc ça c'est
le premier point
le second point c'est quand même les
échelles de temps effectivement sont
variables
quelle est la place aujourd'hui dans une
prospective et dans l'élaboration d'une
stratégie de l'évaluation et des
séquences d'évaluation de réorientation
éventuellement des décisions qui ont été
prises dans un certain nombre de
domaines
cela me paraît absolument essentiel
troisième point c'est une question nous
avons aujourd'hui de façon
institutionnelle
bon un futur commissariat la stratégie à
la prospective qui se dégage et j'ai
envie de dire un qui se dessine
2 un conseil économique social et
environnemental qui est certes composé
d'une délégation mais également de
section lesquels sexion émettent des
avis des préconisations qui partent du
présent avec un diagnostic partagé
disputer pour aboutir à un consensus
avec l'ensemble de la société civile
organisée et nous avons le parlement
quelle articulation entre ces trois
espaces 1
titus ionel précaution voulez vous êtes
inquiète de cette articulation je ne
suis pas de la maison tels que je pense
qu'elle doit être utile parce que ce ne
sont pas les mêmes levier pour autant
qu'elle va être l'articulation organisé
entre eux ces intelligences collectives
dans ces trois institutions deux qui
existent et une troisième qui se dessine
si vous me permettez je voudrais
également insisté sur la qualité de la
dispute parce que j'entends bien les
experts mais on a constaté compris au
travers des différentes interventions
que bon hein l'expertisé tu est parfois
contesté les indicateurs interrogé donc
la qualité donc de la dispute de façon
non seulement aboutir autant que faire
se peut un diagnostic partagé
mais un sens donner aux orientations qui
vont être prises en matière de retraite
si le diagnostic était et j'ai envie de
dire globalement partagé le sens qui a
été donnée n'était en revanche pas
partagée et nous sommes à la veille de
la conférence de la pauvreté et de
l'inclusion sociale
le diagnostic partagé c'est que une des
conséquences de la réforme des retraites
a été l'explosion de la pauvreté chez
les retraités
donc nous avons là à ce sont les experts
en la matière
les statistiques donc l'insee des
chiffres non contestée qui porte ce
constat ce n'est pas la cgt ce sont les
chiffres qui portent ce constat donc
voilà comment nous avançons dans ces
différentes problématiques
merci madame de toutes ces remarques la
question de l'évaluation là aussi
connaissant les travaux diane al gore je
pense que nous allons largement la
bordée sur la deuxième table ronde toute
dernière intervention et puis nous
conclurons cette première mais on va
continuer après encore faire un long
moment ci merci andré jean guérin
membre du conseil d'administration de la
fondation nicolas hulot pour la nature
et ben ali l'homme part dans et membre
du conseil économique social et
environnemental le monde est finie et
maintenant on le sait depuis une bonne
cinquantaine d'années de façon publique
et cela change
sans doute les avenirs possibles le pib
est moins corrélé au bien-être et même
l'os et des oeufs ou l'union européenne
aujourd'hui ont engagé des travaux pour
multiplier les indicateurs et un
question est la suivante comment peut-on
articuler le travail prospectif à une
représentation opératoire de valeur
concrète débattu des valeurs concrètes
ce n'est pas les grandes valeurs de
l'humanisme goût de la république
selanne sont intangibles
mais c'est quel écart de revenus par
exemple dans dix ans dans 20 ans au sein
de la communauté nationale
quelle indépendance énergétique
quelle capacité à influencer l'union
européenne et le monde des choses aussi
précise costa est derrière quels
indicateurs vont pouvoir orienter la
construction des politiques publiques et
ensuite leur évaluation
alors le cea une petite expérience
partagée avec le cnjs et le commissariat
général au développement durable sur un
débat ouvert une ouverture le débat sur
les indicateurs de développement durable
comment voit-on ça dans une approche de
la prospective
merci là encore question très central
madame en a terminé avec vous a fait
attendre merci je vais très très rapide
en fait c'est une question sur le fait
qu'en jusqu'à maintenant j'ai le
sentiment qu'on a justement pas
énormément parler des valeurs
or est-ce que dans l'état actuel de
de questionnements de crise ou de
changement qui nous qui nous préoccupe
est ce que il n'ya pas un préalable à
envisager à un vrai débat et une
redéfinition de nos valeurs pour
envisager des finalités qui orienterait
notre nos explorations et décision en
effet les indicateurs de bien-être
beaucoup d'experts travaillent
maintenant sur l'économie du bonheur
c'est un élément très très important
qu'on peut rajouter au débat y compris
prospectifs
les tout derniers mois la table ronde
c'est joël bourdin qui va conclure jean
pierre raffarin souhaitez-vous pas avant
une courte remarques sur tout ce qui
vient d'être dit notamment sur les
retraites
moi je suis assez d'accord avec lui
quand il nous dit que la prospective
doivent débroussailler à la hache
le problème c'est qu'on ne gouverne pas
lâche donc de toute façon entre la
prospective et la gouvernance yann
dialectique il faut il faut faire vivre
cette dialectique laisser l'art le débat
où les valeurs doivent pouvoir exister
il faut il faut accepter l'idée et sans
forcément que ce soit le mot dispute
qu'il soit le mieux approprié mais en
tout cas débat pour faire en sorte qu'
il est clair qu'il doit y avoir
nécessairement 7
au fond cette capacité à dégager des
lignes d'avenir avec une certaine forme
de netteté mais aussi qu'on veuille bien
comprendre que la société elle est
quelquefois aussi en cristal et que
lâche n'est pas l'outil de travail
numéro un d'un gouvernement
merci et que des zooms neil voulais dire
à son âge quand même non non je suis
désolé d'avoir à mener le débat
tellement sur les retraites alors que
rend réalité le vrai problème en france
et sur lesquels la gauche et la droite
sont complices depuis 40 ans ils
sous-emploi et les partenaires sociaux
aussi aussi bien côté patronat que
salarié si on n'avait pas une situation
de sous-emploi aussi en divx je parle
pas que du chômage avec des problème
absolument majeur sur les jeunes
les seniors le problème la question 13%
des ventes à venir
on nous avons fait en france le choix de
l'ajustement par le sous-emploi il faut
l'assumer faut le reconnaître faut
savoir comment on peut y remédier à
françois racheter j'irai mais évidemment
il faut se planter des tons cèdre tout
de suite parce que le futur n'attend pas
et si on attend trop par exemple plus de
degrés sur la planète à l'horizon 2100
c'est trop tard c'est déjà trop tard
éventuellement sera plus 3 +422 rêvez
pas +2 et puis enfin à grigor c'est le
visage j'ai envie de dire oui bien sûr
les instruments de mesures sont
essentielles par exemple évoqué l'emploi
le taux d'emploi me paraît être un bien
meilleur indicateur que le taux de
chômage
malheureusement la france est toujours
pas bon prix en dépit des sommets
européens merci non on va en rester là
désolé pour ne pas empiéter sur notre
deuxième table ronde importante au moins
autant que celle-ci joël bourdin s'il
vous plaît pour la conclusion notre
président en conclusion c'est beaucoup
dire ce que la table ronde a été assez
riche et et tout le monde en tête ce qui
ce qui a été exprimé
on a eu une bonne idée finalement la
délégation de la prospective du sénat et
sa soeur la délégation a prospective du
du conseil économique social et
environnemental de de nous donner
rendez-vous notre premier rendez-vous de
réflexion sur ce sujet parce que la
délégation prospective du sénat exige
depuis quelques années la délégation à
prospecter du céser existe depuis trois
ans 2 2 1 et donc le président de le
voit et le président bailly ont souhaité
qu'on fasse quelque chose ensemble
on a fait cela 1 et c'est pas c'est pas
facile c'est la première fois je crois
d'ailleurs que conseiller économique et
sociale es et le sénat travaille
ensemble sur un sujet comme celui ci et
on a finalement on est tombé pile
sans doute un et on est tombé pile
puisque vous êtes nombreux et merci
d'être venu pour évoquer ce sujet la
prospective et dans l'air du temps bien
évidemment un puisque même le
gouvernement en juin ou en juillet a
décidé de demander à mme ana morau de
faire un rapport sur sur la prospecter
donc il ya une convergence dans ce
domaine il faut bien dire que nous
vivons dans dans la dictature de de
l'instant 1
je suis à la commission des finances où
je juge que cette année j'aurai on aura
voté un budget pour l'année 2012 donc en
décembre l'année dernière et qu'on aura
voté je crois 4 1 4 collectif budgétaire
c'est à dire qu'on aide
on n'est plus dans le domaine de la
prévision un an on est dans le domaine
de la prévision à trois mois et encore
on se demande si bien d'ailleurs
il est certain qu'on aura un collectif
la semaine prochaine est certain qu'on
aura un collectif au mois de février
pour ça devient ça devient devient folle
on est donc bien évidemment on sent bien
que derrière tout cela il ya des grandes
forces et qu' il faudrait que on est des
perspectives un peu plus encourageantes
certainement mais cohérente
alors la presse l'idée de prospective
n'est pas nouvelle puisque nous avons eu
la chance d'avoir un commissariat au
plan
20 qui a été performant pendant très
longtemps et comme ça et aux plans qui
allaient au delà de la prospective
puisqu'ils allaient jusqu'à établir une
cohérence dans les décisions je veux
dire c'était assez c'était assez
ambitieux 1 et mais depuis quelques
années bien sûr en 2005 premier mini
c'était de villepin on est passé on est
passé à autre chose mais il ya de beaux
restes
un ya de bons restes quand même que la
prospective on en fait un on en fait on
a l'a fait au corps
on en fait au cas sont on en fait dans
on en fait bien sûr à la datar avec qui
d'ailleurs nous avons l'occasion de
travailler la délégation a prospecté
puisqu'en on a engagé un rapport sur
l'avenir des territoires avec la datar
un beau sujet et est donc tout cela nous
nous conduit à aller un peu plus loin
peut-être pas jusqu'à ils ont l'idée
d'une une planification parce que je
pense qu'on tient pas suffisamment de
manette pour rétablir une cohérence à ce
point mais on a besoin disons d'une
perspective beaucoup plus long je crois
que c'est ce qui se dégage de ce débat
et on a surtout besoin d'une prospective
disons un peu plus généralisée parce que
là vous avez parlé madame d'une
prospective balkanes à lindahl
balkaniser c'est vrai il ya beaucoup
d'endroits en fait d'un prospective mais
il n'ya pas n'y a pas d'endroit où se
réunit pour faire quelques pour
présenter dix ont des idées un peu plus
globalisé un don sur le plan de de la
méthode pourra qu on aboutit pour la
première partie à l'idée que il faut
continuer à approfondir la prospective
mais la pause mais mais la prospective
c'est aussi l'appel aux acteurs à j'ai
eu l'occasion et dernière non il ya deux
ans de présenter un rapport ici
d'ailleurs dans cette salle sur le pacte
social ou en insisté justement sur la
nécessité de rassembler les acteurs
sociaux pour arriver à dix on a à faire
en sorte que ce pays est disons vivent
et non pas vive par l'invectivé
l'insulté mais vivent par des des
discussions et est d accord sur
l'essentiel et donc c'est pour ça que
d'un deuxième partie nous allons aborder
la pas la méthode la mise en oeuvre avec
les acteurs sociaux merci
aurait remercié bien sûr tous les
participants qui sont autour de moi et
qui ont fait vivre ce débat comme je
remercie d'ailleurs le président bailly
qui va prendre ma place et qui va avec
d'autres participants parlait de la
suite de ce sujet merci beaucoup
voilà pour cette rencontre sur l'avenir
de la nouvelle planification stratégique
pour revoir cette réunion notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très bonne fin
de journée à tous